is there any chance I could come back to
61st Street an Agnus would welcome me
back with open arms and so would I and
just like that we're back welcome to
season 2 of the official guilded age
podcast I'm Tom Myers and some things
haven't changed my orders are simple I'm
to find a man with birth position and
money and I'm Alicia Malone we'll
separate facts from fiction as we delve
into the drama and Intrigue as you said
yourself to the others we must never
surrender to threesss to yield is to
lose I have no intention of yielding but
doing nothing is no longer an option and
the battles that consumed guilded age
Society may I see a list of the guests
yes you can Mrs Aster join our curated
guest list as we go behind the scenes to
get the scoop from the people who bring
the Gilded Age to life this was a time
for me when America really became
America Tom this season the new and old
Collide and this time Alicia it's time
to pick a side in the battle between old
and new New York I wouldn't like to see
you pay the price for backing the losing
side well you're right about one thing
Mrs Aster I certainly intend to find
myself on The Winning Side find the
official guilded AG podcast on Max or
wherever you listen to podcasts starting
on Sunday October 29th
[Music]